chile un sueño para los migrantes
atraídos por la fuerte economía chilena
miles de emigrantes decidieron cruzar la
frontera y aventurarse hacia el país
austral si bien en un millón 400 mil
inmigrantes provenientes de venezuela
que son los más numerosos
también hay peruanos haitianos y
colombianos los venezolanos que huyen de
la crisis siguen llegando en busca de
nuevas oportunidades
muchos de ellos entran por la frontera
con perú y bolivia la mayor cantidad de
haitianos llegó entre 2016 y 2017 cuando
podían entrar como turistas sin visa y
regularizar luego su situación si
encontraban trabajo al ver esa ola
migratoria en abril de 2018 el gobierno
de sebastián piñera abrió la posibilidad
para que cientos regularizarán su
situación jurídica porque no da la
oportunidad porque tú sabes cuando dejas
a niños pequeños para un porvenir
pero cuando lo tienen en su país la
medida excedió las expectativas del
gobierno que retrocedió pidiendo visas
consulares según el ministerio del
interior de chile si la salida de
haitianos del país ha aumentado un 81
por ciento respecto a 2020 la cantidad
de migrantes sigue siendo alta en la
última semana los brotes de xenofobia
demuestran que un sector de la población
reciente su presencia al acusarlos de
quitarles el empleo y las oportunidades
en iquique la ciudad más grande del
norte la primera a la que llegan los
migrantes fue escenario de violencia
contra venezolanos las imágenes causaron
la condena mundial a pesar de este
panorama cientos de personas entre ellos
venezolanos aún quieren migrar a chile
con el sueño de vivir en uno de los
países más ricos de suramérica